well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and it's John the Humphrey over in
this corner we're gonna watch the new
extended TV spots Star Wars the last
Jedi awake right now if I sound a little
office because I'm recovering from a
cold I have a really nasty ringing ear
right now Licensed to Ill however I was
like I gotta watch some trailers at
least dude this is gonna make you feel
better this is gonna brighten up your
soap so I'm excited for this movie
[Music]
[Music]
that's really bad
[Music]
I knew very carefully
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
dude ray man who isn't isn't the point
of being a Jedi that you have to like
balance out all your emotions and be
equilibrium about it because she looked
pretty mad there
I'm afraid well that's what the that's
what they're teasing that she might go
to the dark side she might turn bad I
think because the trailers have been so
up in your face about it yeah that she's
not going to be turning yeah otherwise
I'll be like well that kind of is
annoying that of trailers revealed I
don't think that we would set up ray
only to have her theories are not fully
baigan but I'm all for I'm 100% in for
exploring her being tempted by it
oh yeah and her toying with the idea of
maybe she you know all that stuff in the
last trailer would like go ahead meet
kylo and Luke being questionable at
train with the shot I got me really
excited was the nostalgia shot yeah
because I didn't even think about that
that was the shot that got me excited
yeah out of everything here for some
reason that was the one it's also I
think the newest image from this trailer
to souls like yeah new scene I got one
don't get cocky could hope they play
that flashback I hope every scene nobody
walks in there he just looks up in a
little thought bubble appears and you
see the image I love the images in these
trailers especially for this particular
movie like every image seems like a very
striking like composed yeah give that
scene in whatever that sinister-looking
places with the red backdrop and like
this it looks like every image could be
a painting yes every image could be like
a poster right that like red crystal
tunnel thing yeah that white barren
desert with the red smoke and ah yeah
every single image there's a few new
images here Oscar Isaac looking out a
window
yeah yeah yeah I'm excited to see him
fight phasma that's that's one of the
biggest things that looking forward to
in this movie well it really built it up
in the last one so it's about time we
get it in this one yeah 55 seconds on
YouTube is number one on trending right
now apparently according to the YouTube
it stores I got tickets for two days in
a row I got it for the day it comes out
and I got it for the very next morning
as well
and somehow in between this all managed
to put out yeah what you'll do is you'll
shoot it edit it upload it head right
back what it feels like it could be that
weekend all right guys well do you think
ray will turn to the bad side definitely
so they call it right this isn't it's a
bad bad side make sure you get mine
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and please
go join us over at patreon become a
patron oject today have a lot of fun
perks going on over there and also uh
check out our a Greg saw sketch while
you're at it put a lot of work over the
past couple weeks find out if there are
people to see it